our very first American brand is an
important one the negotiations begin
pampers
but our pint-sized counterpart is having
none of it and that's something of a
relief we can't do without pampers many
parents would agree they can't do
without disposable diapers and pampers
are a market leader but what about other
products from big-name US brands this
some on the radio was French so that's
fine the toys were all made in China or
Europe except for this bus which is from
Sesame Street the famous American
children's TV series and the story about
the little gorilla is by an American
author so both of those will have to go
and now the radio switch to jazz and
most of that comes from the US this is
Harry Connick jr. a u.s. artist so we'll
have to turn this off that's too bad but
a bit of peace and quiet won't hurt
either here in the children's bedroom
there's a clock made in the USA that can
go my refrigerator is about connect
which sounds like a German brand but
vulcanized has been a part of the
whirlpool group for years and that's an
American company so my refrigerator is
actually American so playing by the
rules the refrigerator would have to be
turned off but we'll make an exception
this time this neighborhood in central
Berlin is no exception it's home to some
American fast food chains avoiding those
would probably be good for your health
then there's Hollywood exports good for
light entertainment but there are other
options
back to the ubiquitous McDonald's and
Coca Cola these are two US brands that
have long since gone global
so what's a burger lover to do the
burgers here are more expensive than in
the American chain but the quality of
the meat is better and there's
personalized service delicious fries and
a soda made in Hamburg time to head back
the picture on the wall is by American
artist Roy Lichtenstein that must go and
this smartphone might be from a South
Korean manufacturer but the operating
system is from the US the tablet uses an
American browser and most of the apps on
it are US made so no tablet no
smartphone no internet it would be hard
to get by without American software
there are alternatives though but unless
you're an expert figuring those out
could be time-consuming and would all
the apps be fully compatible with the
new software and operating system
American brands are everywhere in
Germany and have been for years but
there are widely available alternatives
for most of them apart from the software
and perhaps the disposable diapers a
market that here in Germany is dominated
by US brands